dessert that's 10 calories it's perfect
for the girlies who need dessert every
day and like sour candy and like to
Crunch on ice the ice a little bit
powder A Little Wheel we're making iced
lasagna okay oh I don't know who needs
to hear this but ice is not dessert
sugar-free artificially flavored ice
still not dessert now I just want to say
no Hate to this Creator everyone's on
their own food Journey so please please
please be respectful here I'm also not
diagnosing anyone here but this practice
of eating ice in place of any food never
mind dessert is about as textbook Pro a
and a Reddit forum
as it gets here if you want to try this
amazing cool whatever eat your ice
however you like your ice but also maybe
get your iron check and like Google the
word Pika because that might be what's
going on here but please guys For the
Love of All That is Holy please do not
share this online this kind of content
has the power to do so so so much harm
I'm so tired